o Olá eu me chamo Natália Lopes e hoje
eu vim aqui contar para vocês como é que
a minha vida mudou completamente por
causa de um pinguim eu me lembro como é
que se fosse ontem do dia que nós faz
trouxer tô pinguim para dentro de casa
era pinguim no café da manhã pinguim do
almoço que eu vim na janta eles só
falavam disso não demorou muito para que
o meu pai e o pinguim se tornasse
melhores amigos ele vive insistindo sabe
porque eu brincasse um pinguim mas eu
era a única menina que time e já não me
bastasse ser gótica tem um pinguinho de
estimação quando todo mundo tem um pet
do momento não era tipo de coisa que eu
consegui achar tão legal mas o pinguim
era um teto e descolado ele era tipo um
Pokémon tava sempre evoluindo certo de
ele chegou bem de mansinho e me
apresentou para sua amiga raposa sabe o
danado sabia como aliciar Meninas
inocentes que gostam de D
e foi como comer a minha comida
preferida pela primeira vez só que agora
numa versão vegano é Clara eu aprendi em
três missões que os meus pais sobre o
pinguim o primeiro era que ele não
ficava doente a segunda era que ele não
era um pirata e a terceira aqui dava
para ganhar dinheiro com pingo às vezes
eu precisava de um dinheiro sabe para
fazer um trabalho aqui em uma arte ali
daqui a pouco eu tava lá na internet
titio titio trocar um lero com pinguim e
ele sempre vinha sabe com esquema sabe
tipo um programa livre e eu enfim
precisava sobreviver eu fui viciando eu
fui ficando cada vez mais compulsiva
primeiro eu comecei com os programas
gratuitos em pouco tempo eu já estava
aceitando dinheiro em troca de programa
era como se a minha vida fosse uma
Matrix eu tinha tomado a pílula vermelha
e conseguia ver agora Toda a realidade
do mundo o pinguim havia me transformado
é uma garota de programa livre se ainda
não caiu a ficha para você eu tô falando
do tux o mascote do Linux sistema
operacional que foi responsável e mudar
a minha vida e vai ser responsável e
mudar a sua vida também quando meu pai
brincava comigo eu dizer que o pinguim
não ficava doente ele queria ensinar
segurança e privacidade era mais seguro
navegar pela plataforma do pinguim
porque os programas de malware
conhecidos como Os vírus são em sua
maioria escritos para as pessoas enfim
que gostam de se debruçar na janelas no
Windows - doenças menos vírus maior
segurança a maioria dos vírus ela tem a
intenção de entrar roubar e ficar ali
roubando os estados igual parasita mesmo
entendem importância de ter seus dados
expostos por Tais vírus é essencial para
que você tenha alto no me privacidade
para que você
e não se torna um refém do sistema
quando o meu pai dizia que o pinguim ele
não era um pirata ele tava falando na
importância de empreender de maneira é
de que legal quando eu escolhi usar um
software livre no lugar de um Software
Pirata eu não estou cometendo um crime
quando meu pai minha mãe resolveu
empreender lá na internet nos anos 90
saindo muito caro para empresa não ter
várias licenças Microsoft não tem um
Software Pirata estava fora de cogitação
Já que as multas previstas para empresas
que pra tinha esse tipo de crime digital
são exorbitante se o sistema operacional
que você usa pirata se o programa que
você usa é pirata sinto informar você
não é um cara esperto que economizou um
reais e não pagar pelo programa você é
um criminoso uma prática que pode
quebrar sua empresa no momento em que
ela estiver no seu áudio e
se sinta ganhar dinheiro com um pinguim
pois eu sou o resultado de uma educação
financiada pela empresa dos meus pais
uma empresa sem por cento livre e filho
de peixe peixinho é hoje eu sou sim ou e
uma das programadores da plataforma
empresa digital uma Startup de base
código livre construídas com tecnologias
Livres por duas mulheres em um homem
dois usuários do Linux e um deles uma
melhor amiga e um amor pra vida como uma
empresa livre nós temos a missão de
facilitar a vida do Empreendedor através
da promoção da Autonomia e da liberdade
de empresário frente a esse
totalitarismo imposto pela tecnologia
proprietária Entenda eu também uso o
programa proprietário certas inovações
pagas aceleram meu tempo mas nada se
compara a construção de algo que é para
ser usado pela humanidade
as boas ideias precisam ser livres e
compartilhadas e gente fala sério eu tô
no TED Talks em São Carlos na capital da
tecnologia Eu Queria muito tar
comemorando esse momento mas esse é o
momento de reflexão é hoje eu faço
partes do 0,2 por cento da população que
tem diploma de doutorado dos 9.8 por
cento das mulheres que são sócios em uma
Startup Eu também faço parte dos quinze
por cento que me deram mais cardápio
Oi e esse lugar que eu cheguei ele é
muito solitário falta a mulher falta
mulher preta falta veado e é por isso
que hoje eu vou resgatar Elza Soares o
meu país é o meu lugar de fala É Brasil
que se fala eu sou uma mulher branca
Latina e privilegiada esse hoje em 2021
eu consegui alcançar Esse posto de
liderança e de dona da minha própria
história foi por causa do pinguim por
isso é meu dever compartilhar na
história na esperança que ela possa e
principalmente empoderar mulheres a
buscarem posições de liderança através
da tecnologia se for livre é melhor hoje
No Brasil existem 20 milhões de
brasileiros que sofrem com a falta do
desemprego enquanto isso na tecnologia
existe uma realidade tô
o contrário não existe desemprego e
muito pelo contrário faltam
profissionais qualificados eu tô falando
de ser de 100 mil vagas criadas por ano
uma demanda com as faculdades não
conseguem suprir nem a metade disso
então Justamente esse profissional ele
tá super disputado a tapa pelas empresas
e e eu tô falando assim de Salários que
vão de 8 10 15 25 mil reais talvez você
esteja pensando lá essa coisa de pinguim
ou é para mim não mas talvez você não
saiba você tem um pinguim com você ele
tá em todo lugar de maneira onipresente
de fato se você usa a internet você tá
filosofando com pinguim o seu Android é
um software livre O Facebook é um
software livre o Google é um software
livre e sabe de mais uma coisa que o som
e ele faz por você que o proprietário
não faz não passa de mágica você pode
não simples comando copiar todo o
programa e usar como você quiser isso
quer dizer que você pode criar o seu
próprio Google você pode criar o seu
próprio Facebook e ainda concorrer com
eles o Linux eo pinguim ele é
praticamente todo o sistema da internet
toda economia mundial desde o sistema de
Bolsa de Valores alpix do Banco Central
tudo roda em Linux por isso para mim a
linha histórica é Clara é pré pinguim e
pós-peeling muito antes da pandemia
acontecer eu já tinha entrado em modo de
transformação digital quando ela chegou
eu já estava preparada não é que eu
previa alguma coisa do tipo a pandemia
Só ressaltou aos olhos o Óbvio de uma
mudança que ocorria de forma acelerar
e ela tava vindo com tudo mas algumas
pessoas estão tentando evitar eles
estavam tentando continuar ali no mundo
dinossauro e essa mudança ela acaba
incomodando muito porque ela te obriga a
sair da sua zona de conforto a encarar
uma dor de aprender uma nova linguagem e
aprender a usar um software enfim de ter
que lidar com a dor que você achava que
não ia mais ter que enfrentar mesmo já
tendo conquistado um diploma e três
momentos no fim foram necessários para o
que eu chegasse aonde eu cheguei o
primeiro deles eu chamo de Diagnóstico
eu já tava no fim do meu doutorado
Quando aconteceu o atentado terrorista
em Paris e isso me impulsionou a
identificar que um momento de mudança
ele era muito maior do que entregar um
texto no papel eu precisava de uma tese
que tivesse fora dos padrões da ABNT e
que foi
o nível adequado linguagem do novo mundo
e é por isso que eu rompe as barreiras e
construir um modelo virtual de tese
sendo Então a primeira dez de virtual do
Mundo Entenda eu poderia perder o meu
diploma já que não é possível integrar
uma uma uma tese sem ser no papel mas
isso foi eliminado com a entrega de um
modelo empírico não um modelo qualquer
um modelo que tem como base a filosofia
do pinguim um modelo que usa tecnologias
livres para que outra pessoa possa
copiar e fazer ainda melhor na defesa da
Minha tese Eu também escancaram Regência
da transformação digital principalmente
relacionada à produção de conhecimento
científico um destaque é claro para
ciências humanas áreas muitas
tradicionais que é inventam enfrentar a
dor de encarar que os seus pressupostos
caíram e que a tecnologia enfim trouxe
transformações conceituais
e sobretudo acerca de um homem sobre a
liberdade do Homem Sobre a máquina sobre
a liberdade da máquina a Bia
Inteligência Artificial do Bradesco ou
não aceita mais a sede o código usado na
programação não pode mais ser racista
mas na universidade está tudo bem usar a
sua bibliografia racista homofóbica e
misógina o novo humano é sobre ética o
novo humano é sobre poder e o pinguim
ele é a base para uma sociedade um novo
humano constrói de maneira colaborativa
e não hierárquica é por isso que o Linux
ele é o maior case de sucesso de um
projeto colaborativo que deu certo o
segundo momento eu chamo de desapego foi
quando eu joguei todos os meus livros de
papel fora e a partir desse dia
como fazer tudo pela internet usando o
meu Android é claro lê fazer compras
andar de carro paquerar trabalhar eu não
precisava sair de casa para fazer mais
nada e ela interessante porque as
pessoas ficavam um pouquinho de guinada
suas Como assim você não vai no mercado
hoje elas não conseguem imaginar como
elas vão se alimentar sem o iFood eu não
tô dizendo que você precisa pegar todos
os seus livros e em jogar fora mas uma
hora você vai ter que desapegar e quanto
mais você Desapega maior é a chance de
você se tornar um líder jogar os livros
fora foi um meu ato simbólico de
desapegar de uma formação que eu levei
12 anos para construir e que precisava
sair de cena para abrir espaço para
inovação se você mulher a sua jornada
vai ser muito mais difícil e não se
engane com os programas promotores e
sentimos as mulheres eles querem apenas
a mulher que já tem sucesso de
preferência
o que já é rica e que fala inglês o
resto é puro marketing acredite em mim
se você escolher a partir de hoje se
tornar um amigo do pinguim a sua
carreira vai disparar E você nunca mais
vai estar sozinho sempre vai ter um
fórum um alguém em algum lugar do mundo
disposto eu te ajudar o terceiro
movimento eu chamo de enfrentar foi
quando eu precisei vender a síndrome do
impostor e aceitar que eu não era mais
uma acadêmica agora eu era uma mulher na
tecnologia era um dia de trabalho
qualquer e eu tava dentro do Uber quando
o motorista me perguntou o que que você
faz eu respondi eu trabalho com
tecnologia EA reação da pessoa foi uma
reação muito diferente de quando eu
perguntava é você fazia e eu respondia e
eu sou professora de filosofia Filosofia
é chato né admissão da resposta da
tecnologia me pro
e trazia um ensinamento que eles
precisavam ser compartilhado e foi nesse
momento então que eu entendi que a
tecnologia me dar a oportunidade de
revolucionar ela me dava oportunidade de
fazer algo que eu não conseguia fazer
com a filosofia eu queria fazer algo que
pudesse ajudar as pessoas a se tornarem
Donos das suas próprias vidas EA
filosofia que capaz de transformar pelo
tecnologia é a filosofia do pinguim
quando a pandemia Então chegou eu
assisti ali no conforto do meu home
office é milhões de pessoas com a mesma
classificação que eu é ficar completo
desespero mesmo porque não sabiam fazer
uma vídeo conferência E quando eu
percebi que o meu pouco domínio com
tecnologia me deixou a frente em um
momento como esse me deu a certeza que
eu precisava divulgar filosofia do
pinguim para que qualquer pessoa consiga
assim como eu transitar do professora de
filosofia desempregada para
o produto escalavel inovador e livre
venha você também se tornar um amigo do
pudim sigam mulheres pretas